c'est parti attention vite et il
n'arrive pas un peu vite la lui c'est
leonardo
notre cher qui n'a peur de rien on est
des gommes
rappel ce genre gros nous nourrit
si les gros nounours était super violent
moi ça roule et toi tu roules donatello
et à fréchette
comment ça
ce contrôle deux routes
puis moi c'est michelangelo le triple b
brillant balèze et bien sûr boca et mick
et les gares
nous allons créer une armée s'équipent
les gars
tu nous ressort le style iroquois ça te
fait bien fait et petit maroc
une chakou ce gigantisme si tu veux
donner à fond avec eux ça va faire mal
ces trucs sont trop mortel ouais
carrément trop mortel